welcome to winners on a Wednesday it
great to have you here you know I always
say that if you become successful or
become financially free please tell me
because I'd love to interview you on
Windows on a Wednesday and inspire other
people a lot of people hide away and
they don't want to come on the show and
Abby she's on the Academy and I bumped
into her at the academy social dinners
that we had and I found out that she's a
secret financially free property
entrepreneur so I finally managed to
persuade her to come out share her story
of persistence education hard work and
now she's financially free so Abby
welcome to winners on the Wednesday
thank you I'd really like to really
fight ticket year you did tell me why
tell me what's going on what happened um
because I felt I needed to make a
certain amount more than well I I was
anything like as a dentist and I thought
yeah if I can't do maybe double what I
was earning then I can tell people my
story so yeah that's all yeah why I was
like no I'm not ready but fun I felt I'd
not done enough so yeah you've done
quite a bit how many how many deals have
you got um I'm for all together yeah I'm
working on a fifth one yeah working on a
fifth yeah currently going like to the
deals you've got what are the deals what
are they consist of and to multi lets's
service apartment two properties that
you own yeah and then two properties
where they rent around yeah and you're
making a total profit all together on
the HMOs of how much total let's say 100
of the one-five about 1,500 yeah and
then the service department yeah it's
fluctuates between yeah it depends quite
seasons like 500 and pair each property
and now he's picking up Isabel 1k so so
you're probably all about altogether
about 3000 pounds a month yes well thank
him I know slightly more that's but
that's a good achievement that's I mean
I know for you you wanted to you wanted
to hit a certain target before you told
people but one last idea over that
dinner yeah you said I'm I'm robbing
people of the opportunity to do the same
yeah absolutely
so awesome great thank you for agreeing
to come to the offices
share the story so talk to me about your
background and why you chose to get into
property well um I've been a dentist's
where I qualified in 2003 in Nigeria
then we qualified here in England 2006
and I worked as a dentist since then
initially just as a private dentist and
mixed NHS and then I furthered my
education and start doing them more
streamlined dentistry like that do root
canals so anyway the my duties I enjoyed
it but I just felt you know I can't do
this for the rest of my life I know when
and my husband just got married we talk
about all prophecies the way to go
my mom has got a few properties and she
literally leaves of them so my sister
told my younger sister she told me about
Oh have I listened to all these prophecy
books I should go listen to read that
Porter and Poor Dad and then when I
listen to you know it's like the scales
fell off my eyes you know and I was like
seriously I've been slaving away
literally not doing much with the money
I was getting and yeah I just said okay
let's try this and immediately changed
the way I was renting out my first
prophecy because UK when when did you
come to the crash course I think I think
November yeah that 2018 last back ended
last year and we did a piece on HMOs yes
yeah and you did something extraordinary
and this what you did is the reason I
really wanted you on the show what did
you do with your property and well I
just some changed them the way I rented
it yeah awesome so you had a prop so you
own to put one property so did you live
in it no we're not leaving any we used
to live in it so you became you were
like an accidental landlady yeah so you
bought a house to live in it change your
circumstances moved out rented it out
but then on the crash course you were
thinking I could choose that as a HMO so
how much rent were you getting how much
you gain now and then I was getting
700 pounds rains where is it that's seen
your share brother
rather ugly that's quite a lot of rent
really yeah so rather ugly yeah okay so
you're getting 700 yeah and then after
the crash course when you change the
setup how much how much did you stop
getting rent
yeah that's when I say guessing like one
came between my hundred one k just
depends because a net profit times yeah
yeah yeah that's a total win so one list
I'll just calculate so one is to fun 400
as it's Andre then the thus 105 yeah so
1900 he went from 700 Pam rent to 1900
but then of course you got a little
bells yes yes but your profit went from
7:00 to 9:00 to 9:10 that 700 was in my
profits
it was the rains and I seen leader to
pay the mortgage oh yeah so it was fun
that yeah it was the profit
so probably the mortgage wasn't been it
was to six to seven so yeah so the
profit was probably like so probably
four hundred and something more than
double your profit yeah yeah which is
good yeah how do you feel yeah yeah
great yeah obviously it's been a
learning curve you know with dealing
with tenants and all that but so I've
got a company that manages them now so
I'm not too involved like I was at the
beginning so yeah I mean it makes me
feel like yeah yeah what is you know
because initially you know going for
these property causes you know you go
people make you feel very bad about it I
hope you're making the right decision or
not stuff like that you know so yeah
yeah yeah you mean friends yeah family
and friends you hear all sauce you know
people bring you down for for eat you
know like a wasting money and stuff like
that yeah so you made me feel very good
and yeah yeah I thank my sister for like
introducing me to ya the prophecy
journey how did you hear about me well
my colleague in in Barnsley
dentists as well he saw I like
a few property pages on Facebook and
contacted me they have a head of summer
leads so he's a friend of Martin Wong my
Martin is from a patient became a friend
so he then said Oh a friend of his told
him about some leads and I checked on
new Google check the reviews and I was
like how did I not hear about you before
you know check the crash courses he sent
me the link for the crash cart Lauren
no not much in William William William
yeah so he sent me the link for the
crash course that he was going to be in
a Manchester one and I booked I booked
myself into that I'm for dating link to
a few of my other friends
there are also doctors and yeah well
mates at the crash course
yeah the crash course is mind-blowing is
well if the thing is it doesn't matter
how fun it is the bottom line is it was
the crash course that took you from from
making 400 amount of profit to nine ten
hundred per annum of profit off the same
house which is awesome so after that you
then went on to the Academy and you've
system three Dale's I know you're a big
believer in hard work and persistence
it's not been an easy road no no
definitely not talk to us about that
yeah so the one I struggled to learn
about the most was the service
department see with multi-layer marina
is quite easy you know the tenants are
there for at least six months and if you
do your vetting process properly you get
good tenants so I've had the odd tenants
you know that you know midlife hell and
I'm like oh my word do you know why did
I do this for ya it soon turns around
with persistence so with the sales
department it's something as easy as
those getting the service apartment
loading its on the websites on dernier
sold was no you there's a lot to Lena
yeah I think property that I have taken
over my life yeah I'm beginning to
outsource it bits at a time but
initially I just wanted to learn you
know and do all I needed to do yet to
get them success strategy like rent to
serviced accommodation
unless you have really good systems it's
not passive no he's not is very much
active yeah it can be massive yeah yeah
yeah it's not passive yeah I know I
personally think they'll be that you
shouldn't outsource stuff that you have
no idea about yourself definitely that's
why I didn't just give it to a
management company straight away I
wanted to know how the process worked
yeah
so that way because in your hard work it
was actually education yes it's oil
because you were doing education with me
yeah yeah on the academy but then you
were also it's almost like you want it
you want to be doing the practical in
the fair at the same time to get the
full learn yeah definitely that's why we
pay for the education to get the most of
it are you a dentist no you quit okay
end of March this year congratulations
thank you because of property that
you've been able to do that because
obviously if my living have the money I
couldn't have been able to just quit
like that yeah so yeah what does your
husband think of that well you thought I
was crazy I'll be going back and all
that support I have like an ongoing
health issue getting better but the fact
that's you know I couldn't really work
you know prophecy made it possible for
us so I continue like with the bills our
lifestyle stuff like that what you had a
health issue that was potentially going
to affect your work yeah yeah yeah not
potentially it was affecting my work so
I you know I had like this constant pain
and so I wasn't being able to do the
most I could do at work so and I just
knew that yeah yeah like my expiry date
was getting closer sort of for the job
so I really released ramped up you know
the property searches and stuff like
that just really yeah you know what
that's so inspiring because I mean and
this is what I said you needed to come
on the show because there's other people
out there them are the same issues you
you you had a physical you in pain yeah
yeah you had friends and family that
were telling you a crazy even your
husband's not telling myself you didn't
have like a massive pot of money no no
no definitely not
pottsy you got a small bit of that a
little bit of money but not a lot of me
and you chose to put that into education
people-people
no wonder people said you were crazy
yeah you know you're physically not able
to continue the job anymore
and you've got a little bit of money and
you choose to be spent on education
people think that's crazy about what you
get from the education and the people
you know before I got into the Academy
you know it was so lonely you know no
one to talk to
literally you know you saw well I'm good
to go on Facebook groups get you know
put your stuff in but you know there was
no connection to anyone and I just felt
like you know I was lost you know boy
they are kidding me you know I've got
new friends my husband said oh yeah I've
been yeah prophets a friend you know
like he's yet to me they're my stuff
like that well you know it's a whole new
one they just make you feel so welcome
there's no problem that's I would have
that someone else has more experience
yeah so yeah yeah it's fun at the
academy guys are some fantastic yeah
the knowledge yes I'm so I'm gonna
hunted you down yeah you know you can't
you can't hide escape because when you
came to the dinner that you were so
trying to hide yes I was I was the last
to speak I think yeah always there for
everyone think you know yes someone
something else we come to these tracks
from the fact that I've not said
anything but yeah yeah and then it's
like a bit have you done any deals and
you're like yeah we all clap you know
and then I'm thinking yeah I'm surviving
you down on the show talk to me about
some of the lessons then that you've
learned in achieving what you've
achieved yeah that pesto pays and yeah
just constant education because
everything it's you know the business
evolves every day people bring new stuff
you know so it's just to continually
educate yourself and continually improve
you know
don't quit are the first sign of yeah
you know you know a lot of people are
quitting so just be persistent because
if you went through uni like most people
deed it wasn't easy so why would anybody
think you know prophecy is easy so it
does keep a seed surround yourself with
positive people and yeah just yeah
yeah I love that because the thing is
that's so true when you go to school and
you're you know I see people you know at
uni and and they're slogging their guts
out and they stand up to a - am studying
whereas then people think property just
no and the Academy is not a magic wand
it's not you have to ask you only say
take action yeah yeah I think the four
things that I say you need and you've
picked up on a couple of them education
knowledge get the right tools because if
you would take an action without the
knowledge you're screwed education
action persistence and belief in their
fear things that are belief definitely
yeah no because if you don't believe you
can do it you know you just it's quite
easy to just be dissuaded you know for
you to be talked out of it because I
remember when you know a few friends you
know they were like oh are you sure
you're not going to go back to work I'm
like no I'm on the path and you know I'm
almost there I'm almost there you know I
had to downsize a bit you know to be
able to achieve what I wanted to achieve
but yeah I was able to do it and that's
and I feel feel I'm not there so I'm
still just yeah yeah I still got a lot
to do I believe you when will it be
enough when will you say when is the
environment of a right
well we're busy right now I don't know
if there's that point because I'm a very
driven person
I like puts in my best same I keep firm
sets in the target so I don't think
there'll be a point now I can say yes
this is it yeah it's giving me the
opportunity to be with the kids help my
husband help with things I couldn't do
so yeah I'll keep stretching myself you
know as much as I can I giving you not
only a lot more time but the money I
know you've loosen it up a new business
and yeah the business is not a new one
it's been there for a while results were
in the background but now I'm just able
to face it the most delicious and Amazon
business we sell on Amazon oh absolutely
yeah I know you so passionate about that
but then the thing is until you're
financially free sometimes financial
freedom through properties of vehicle
and it can give you the time to then go
and explore
yeah yeah yeah it's been fantastic you
know that we we have the opportunity
that we have you know to do the things
we love because obviously I love the
property and I also love Amazon I love
both so much you know passion of God so
yeah
talk to me about property wise what's
next well now I've been I'm doing a few
viewings it's your fifth deal is that
also rent to rent
um 50 oh no now it's my refurbish Wow
so you're gonna do you gonna have a full
flush because it's good to you know
spread your risk money from to do all
these deals you need take one to the
other to the other you know you just
keep yeah it's moving from one to the
other and it's a likely look at
recycling it's you know there's no point
binging on it you know cuz you refinance
one of your houses right yes yes I'd be
to get some I wrote you're thinking that
you're you at a little house that you're
renting out you're making a few Japan a
month you came on the crash course you
refinanced it you bought another HMO is
that right and you turned that into a
hey Chema so you just that one house
that was giving you three or four
hundred pound a month suddenly you've
now added from that house you've now got
two houses
giving you 1500 pound a month profit and
then obviously the money to set up the
essays and stuff night on the repo no
yeah from more from the rents that was
getting values so when the first si
started making profits then I got the
second one and the second one yeah I was
pretty much so with the money that
you're making at what you're putting it
aside
yeah I'm positive aside I also borrowed
quite a lot talk to me about your
husband at first he thought you were a
bit crazy yes he still thinks you're
crazy
but he's he's like an accountant quite a
diligent numbers kind of guy and he
helps you a lot on the business now who
goes over the properties how important
is it to have because I know you've had
he thinks you're a bit crazy I know some
of your friends have tried to pull you
back but how important is it to have
people in your life they're supportive
yeah
very very important because obviously it
affects your mindset as well if you
don't have those people that supports
you
oh yeah my husband might say oh yeah
well I know when push comes to shove
he's always there for me he's got my
back
it always yeah yeah so very very
important yes exactly
they are you know my friends yeah so
many of them Remmy in say yeah they are
so many I met Chris I think I'm Chris
we're in the same music crash course now
or DfE or both you know so because we
used to we're doing our searches
together so yeah I've just met lovely
fantastic people you know they're always
so happy and when I'm Donna I've had
enough you know yeah they just pick up
the phone there's someone to inspire you
la oh yeah we did that
it happened to us a few months ago I
mean I oh yes so it's not just you and
the Eco past it's you know and then you
hit the next high and I a this has
happened you know so yeah it's fantastic
what would you say to someone who was in
a similar situation to what you were in
before whereby maybe health problems
financial problems working really hard
on a job you don't particularly want to
do forever and then making excuses as to
why it's impossible
what would you say just come on the
crash goes fast that's always
life-changing isn't it yeah come on in
crash girls take actions of others you
know that's my first advice yeah yeah
surround yourself with positive people
yeah I guess educated definitely yes
because the education comes with so much
more so yeah that's great yeah yeah
talking about my life yeah so hopefully
you'll be able to help when used to find
other people are financially free from
the training tell them come on the show
it's not too bad survive yeah yeah yeah
so you get to go from strength to
strength
thank you yeah so guys I hope you found
that inspiring and helpful I think you'd
agree Abby is a wonderful human being
and
really excited to see her journey
potentially we could do a part two with
Abby next year if you are smashing it in
property as a result of my training
please do let me know before I hunt you
down and find you don't forget to
subscribe
smash the like button and drop a
positive comment about our beat below
see you next time thanks so much for
watching
[Music]